merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
allez nous aider à comprendre un peu ce
qu'est le Qatar ce que veut le Qatar
donc cette Coupe du Monde c'est parti
mais à quel prix quand même pour les
travailleurs étrangers on l'a vu dans le
dans le reportage ah bah c'est le prix
du son le prix de la sueur il faut
savoir que le Qatar a importé un million
de travailleurs principalement d'Asie du
Sud-Est et d'Afrique sur la dernière
décennie et c'est ces gens qu'on a
retrouvé sur tous les chantiers de la
Coupe du Monde c'est pas simplement les
stades c'est les routes les ponts
l'aéroport le port le métro le tramway
et donc c'est des gens effectivement qui
sont payés 200 250 dollars par mois et
qui travaillent 60 heures par semaine
dans des conditions assez terribles oui
terrible quand il fait 50 60 degrés
alors évidemment il y a eu des
améliorations parce que effectivement le
il y avait des pressions internationales
d'Amnesty de la presse de l'ONU même et
donc au bout du compte ils se sont dit
il faut quand même faire quelque chose
compte tenu de l'impact de la Coupe du
monde donc c'est d'ailleurs années il y
a eu des réformes plutôt positives
notamment ils sont plus payés en liquide
mais par la banque il y a des arcs
voilà mais c'est encore le problème il y
a la loi et puis l'application de la loi
le problème c'est les hommes d'affaires
qui attariens bah il continue à confiser
des passeports à payer au lance-pierre
il y a eu une manifestation au mois
d'août et mes 60 pauvres asiatiques ont
manifesté parce qu'ils étaient pas payé
depuis 6 mois bon résultat ils ont été
mis à l'avion en 48 heures quel pays
quand même mais c'est grâce à eux le
miracle
qatarien donc oui faut pas oublier il y
a deux toujours deux faces de la
médaille oui ils sont exploités et ils
envoient 11 milliards de dollars chez
eux au Népal au Bangladesh au Pakistan
donc c'est aussi il y a du business
derrière donc mais c'est vrai que les
conditions étaient presque de
l'esclavagisme moderne mais encore une
fois la Coupe du Monde a quand même
permis de mettre le braquer le
projecteur et d'améliorer comme un petit
peu les choses
et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que Amnesty
International réclame un fond de
compensation de 440 millions de dollars
pour ces gens et puis continuent de
mettre la pression après la Coupe du
monde le Qatar il y a 20 ans c'était
encore un petit pays désertique pauvre
qui a connu donc une ascension fulgu
grâce à tous ces gens qui ont construit
finalement oui c'est surtout le projet
d'un homme chez Ahmad chez Rahman c'est
le père de l'émir actuel et donc chez
Ramad on avait marre que son pays
justement soit dans les sables soit
comment dire pauvre etc et donc il
renverse son père en 95 le chef Khalifa
et lui son idée c'est de faire briller
le Qatar de faire rayonner et surtout
d'utiliser la richesse du gaz le gaz of
Shore la plus grande poche au monde que
le Qatar partage avec l'Iran et l'idée
cette richesse on va l'utiliser on va
l'utiliser pourquoi bah pour se
développer pour construire notre pays et
puis pour pour rayonner et pour acheter
partout dans le monde et qu'est-ce qu'il
cherchait enfin il voulait la une
reconnaissance la reconnaissance une
forme de revanche aussi une revanche sur
Dubaï parce qu'entre bédouin il y a
toujours des Bizzbee entre les Emirs il
y a des jalousies donc prends sa
revanche rayonner être indépendant par
rapport à l'Arabie Saoudite parce que le
Qatar a longtemps été vécu sous l'aile
protectrice de l'Arabie Saoudite quand
on regarde la géographie le Qatar c'est
quoi c'est un doigt de sable
qui part de l’arabie Saoudite et qui est
pointé sur l'Iran donc voilà il voulait
être indépendant autonome visible et
reste finalement un grand petit pays
c'est d'ailleurs lui qui crée Al Jazeera
alors évidemment sa place le kata un peu
dans le monde parce que tout à coup tout
le monde découvre un peu ce pays-là
grâce à cette chaîne de télévision non
un monsieur ton premier coup de génie
c'est ça la chaîne je dirais a été créée
en Arabie Saoudite forcément elle a pas
marché compte tenu la censure etc la
pression policière est donc chez Rama
des très malin il se dit tiens je vais
récupérer cette chaîne et on sert sur de
CNN arabe et ça va être une révolution
partout dans le monde arabe et aussi en
Occident parce qu'on découvre tiens
finalement les Arabes ils peuvent parler
comme nous ils ont des reporters partout
dans la région ils sont influents ils
étaient à Kaboul en Irak en Palestine
etc donc de gros moyens et on parle à
tout le monde donc ça ça déjà ça ça
donne un peu la patte du Qatar on parle
à tout le monde y compris aux gens un
peu sulfureux aux gens par exemple que
les Occidentaux ne veulent pas parler
comme les talibans ramasse les
djihadistes notamment ceux de Siri en
Libye etc donc on est dans une dans une
diplomatie j'allais dire 360 degrés on
fait un peu comme notre président Macron
on fait du en même temps tout le temps
c'est qu'on parle aux Israéliens on
parlera à masse on parle au Taliban et
on parle aux Américains et derrière ça
explique que ce soit des avions du Qatar
qui ont finalement sorti les
ressortissants étrangers à Kaboul quand
les talibans sont venus et les
Occidentaux remercier le Qatar parce que
ils nous ont aidé à sortir les
ressortissants donc tout le monde a dit
merci le Qatar et en même temps le Qatar
a un agenda diplomatique est pas
forcément le nôtre nous occidentaux
comme je faisais allusion l'islamisme le
djihadisme il y a eu des connexions
assez opaques en Syrie avec des gens
d'Al-Qaïda carrément et puis nous en
France on a eu malgré tout ce que
j'appelle la zone grise le Qatar a
investi dans l'islam de France et en
Europe partout en Europe dans les
mosquées les écoles coraniques les
prédicateurs etc donc là entre acheter
le royaume Monceau ou le penins ou le
PSG ou Balmain ou Valentino c'est une
chose c'est le business quand on
commence à toucher l'ADN des pays en
trafiquant sur l'islam bah là on se
brûle d'ailleurs le président Macron
l'aura tapé sur les doigts parce que là
on se demande qu'est-ce que veut le
Qatar quelle est l'agenda alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent de l'influence
ils veulent créer des réseaux
d'allégeance de loyauté parce qu'encore
une fois c'est un tout petit pays on l'a
dit 300 000 habitants pas plus grand que
la Corse et puis une petite armée 12000
hommes donc ils tiennent pas deux heures
face à l'Iran face à l'Irak ou l'Arabie
Saoudite donc pour se protéger ils vont
tisser des fils mais dans tous les
domaines économique financier sportif
culturel éducation partout pour se
relier finalement à des grands pays des
grands alliés qui s'ils ont besoin ils
viendront à leur secours et c'est une
population qui est extrêmement riche les
300.000 citoyens cathariens ils sont
extrêmement riches
3 mondial avec le Luxembourg le
Liechtenstein c'est à dire à peu près 90
000 dollars par an par tête d'habitants
le Qatar c'est un peu comme une
multinationale vous avez le PDG qui
s'appelle l'émir vous avez le conseil
d'administration c'est la famille royale
et puis vous avez les actionnaires c'est
les Qatariens les actionnaires qui sont
grassement payés grassement et privé par
l'État-providence parce que tout est
gratuit tout est gratuit c'est tout tout
voilà là petit anecdote je donne le
livre pour récompenser les meilleurs les
100 meilleurs bacheliers là en juin
dernier il a offert une Rolex au 100
meilleurs bacheliers donc voilà c'est
l'opulence c'est la voilà c'est ça ça
reste un pays extrêmement conservateur
ça reste un comités
les femmes c'est pas l'Arabie Saoudite
pendant longtemps l'Arabie Saoudite
c'était vraiment le pays le plus
rétrograde pour les femmes le Qatar ils
sont où habite mais les femmes peuvent
travailler peuvent conduire peuvent
divorcer peuvent voyager mais il reste
une tutelle très forte des mâles de la
jante masculine c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
sort de sponsoring finalement donc pour
voyager pour se marier etc c'est une
société aussi où il y a de la polygamie
qui existe encore ah bah le prince il a
deux femmes son père il femme pourquoi
cette volonté de tenir la Coupe du monde
alors que c'est un pays qui a pas de
tradition de football aucune le sport
là-bas c'est la c'est les courses de
chameaux c'est les courses de chevaux et
la chasse aux faucon pour eux c'est le
Graal du soft power c'est à dire que le
un événement planétaire on est 8
milliards sur terre vous avez peut-être
4 milliards de personnes qui vont
regarder la Coupe du monde donc c'est un
formidable coup de projecteur sur ce
pays encore vous l'avez dit il y a 20
ans qui connaissait DOA qui connaissait
le Qatar personne donc le pari est
réussi maintenant tout le monde connaît
le Qatar tout le monde parle du Qatar
parfois en mal parfois en bien mais en
tout cas ils sont sur la carte du monde
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas fallu quand
même boycotter cette Coupe du monde le
péché originel c'est la FIFA c'est la
FIFA c'est la FIFA donc le le
l'organisation qui gère le foot mondial
qui accorde ce Mondial au Qatar la
France qui va aussi favoriser le Qatar
Nicolas Sarkozy à l'époque c'est lui qui
va aussi ramener des voies africaines
pour qu'il vote pour le Qatar on le
savait tout ça les femmes les LGBT
l'environnement travailleurs le climat
pourquoi le chat donne la Coupe du monde
à un pays où il fait 50 degrés il était
on le sait alors deux trois ans après on
va dire il fait chaud au Qatar on va
mettre en décembre voilà donc il y a une
immense hypocrisie beaucoup d'argent
autour de ça petite anecdote le patron
de la FIFA Jenny and Fantino où est-ce
qu'il habite à Lausanne à Genève non il
habite maintenant à Doha avec sa famille
maintenant c'est un peu tard au moment
où ça se passe de dire ah ben non c'est
pas bien le boycott bah non c'est trop
tard il fallait y penser peut-être avant
mais peut-être que ces grands événements
sportifs maintenant c'est ce genre de
pays qui va pouvoir se les payer je
pense qu'il y a une vraie bascule
géopolitique c'est-à-dire que c'est tout
à fait vrai je pense que maintenant les
grandes compétitions en Occident en
Europe aux États-Unis au Canada il y en
a voyant il y en aura toujours mais
c'est vrai que le golf et l'Asie vont
maintenant prendre de plus en plus de
ses compétitions l'Arabie Saoudite qui
veut même organiser des jeux olympiques
d'hiver le Qatar qui rêve d'organiser
les Jeux olympiques d'été en 2036 il
travaille tout de suite ils sont en
train de travailler sur le dossier
donc voilà ils vont parce que l'argent
parce que malheureusement ou
heureusement je sais pas l'argent achète
tout alors vous n'y serez pas parce que
vous êtes interditifs
un peu sulfureux avec mon collègue de
Figaro georgeman Bruno moi j'y serai pas
mais je trouve c'est je pense que c'est
un objet assez facilement parce que
c'est un jeu de miroir aussi sur cette
mondialisation sur ces nouvelles
puissances émergentes sur nous alors
peut-être pas forcément au Canada vous
êtes le nouveau monde mais nous l'Europe
on est un peu en déclin et là-bas il y a
beaucoup d'argent donc il y a des
fantasmes aussi sur l'islam on l'a dit
l'environnement alors est-ce que c'était
très green d'organiser une coupe du
monde locataire non et en même temps les
katariens disent mais oui mais nos stats
sont climatisés avec de l'énergie
solaire il y a plein de choses une
concentration de toutes les questions
qui se posent aujourd'hui voilà donc il
y a tout ça merci beaucoup